turn around throw what you got you a pal  pal juggernaut take it up a notch oh my  god Wow let me take us down heist music  [Music]  [Music]  it's some kind of monster wait that's  not a monster that's a man wearing  shoulder pads there's only one super  villain whose fashion sense is quite  that dated free Balthazar brat  I want every agent of the scene  immediately it's clear see our closing  fast  kiss wait why what did you call us  brucey you know GRU and Lucy push  together Lucy uh-huh I like it but not a  lot I don't like it get it away that's  what you think  get get the ready for ya  Oh  hello glue haha  what about that sauce Wow Oh girls dance  fight this is not over  [Music]  to you happy birthday dear Dan happy  birthday who's bad  you